all right day 41. i've still got my flu
but i'm getting better
um
language learning is a
an endurance contest as i've said
um i've got another
49 days here
to see what i can achieve in a period of
concentrated study
but
i think it's important not to put as
i've said before not to put undue
pressure on oneself i know that i will
improve
i know that i'm not gonna master korean
in 90 days i'm not going to master
korean in a year
i haven't mastered russian i spent five
years granted not as intensely as i'm
studying now
um
i really haven't i guess the only
language that i
speak at what i would call like a really
advanced level
is french i can pick up any book
literature anything i can have a
conversation on anything
i'm okay
french one language out of 12. i do fine
in japanese chinese spanish i can
conduct business i can understand stuff
have mastered them any language you work
on it's it's always a work in progress
so whatever i achieve in 90 days in
korean i'll be happy and the more time
i'm able to spend on it the better i
will get
so since it's a long-term endurance
contest the important thing is to do
things that we enjoy doing and not to
put pressure on ourselves
i gotta learn this i gotta learn that i
gotta be better i can't make mistakes
forget all of that just enjoy it
so i'm doing now things that i enjoy
doing and at this stage i'm particularly
enjoying doing the following
reading articles on chosen elbow which i
import in the link save words look up
the you know the chinese characters if
they're available for different words
all of this is helping me get a feel for
how the language works how they use
chinese characters i'm tagging some
connector words so that i can review
those
um
i have this general sense of how the
grammar works and i notice some of these
patterns as i'm reading so that's one
activity and that's basically in two
stages one on the computer
saving new words
creating links for them so that i can
then go and read it on my ipad where
it's a little more pleasant to read
using the ilink app
so that's one activity
and the other activity of all the
material that i have to listen to what i
find the most enjoyable to listen to is
kim yong-ha
even though i don't understand it it's
so tantalizing to listen to it his voice
is so pleasant his rhythm
everything about it is very pleasant the
subject matter it's subjects of interest
to me it's literature and
and every so often he'll he'll you know
recite a an excerpt from a book you know
yukio mishima or something well that's
where i'm completely lost because once
you actually get into a book of
literature the language is too difficult
for me but when he's talking about it
and talking about different aspects or
people he met he was in china and
shandong province met some students
whatever that part about i'm able to
pick up more and more and i notice you
know again bits here and bits there uh
but it's enjoyable and it's it's
stimulating to try and get more and more
of it and that's what i'm going to do
and i'm happy and i put in the time
until i get tired of doing that i might
occasionally review some of these
grammar patterns but mostly that's it
and i'll talk to people
but it's those two things what would be
phenomenal for me kim jung-ha has 53
podcasts each of them is roughly an hour
long
if by some magic somewhere there was a
class of advanced korean students in
other words
non-speak native speakers of korean who
were studying korean and if they were
assigned the task of transcribing in
other words taking dictation
transcribing
the 53
podcasts kim jung-ha's podcast
i would have the transcript
because i mean to pay for it it's gonna
cost a fortune but if i could actually
read and then
mine those
transcripts for the words and phrases
and listen again that would be
phenomenal so i'm i'm putting that out
there if there's any place anywhere
people want to take on the task of
trying it would be a great
uh learning
exercise
and i could use them and then we may be
i mean in an ideal world we could
approach kim jung-ha and say look here's
transcripts you want to put transcripts
on your website it's going to help in
terms of
spiders finding your website uh can we
then share it in our community with the
other korean learners
uh but the first thing would be to try
to get the transcripts so if there's
anybody out there with any ideas on how
to get these transcripts that would be
phenomenal one other thing before i
leave you
uh
it's my wife's birthday on the first of
march and it's a bit of a
milestone birthday
and while i enjoy the winter here in
vancouver with the skiing and the hockey
my wife doesn't she likes to play golf
so we are going for a week
to escondido california
near san diego
and we're going to just take it easy and
play golf and celebrate her birthday if
anyone is in the san diego area we could
even meet up there i don't know
so i will be attempting
hopefully the wi-fi connections there
are good
and i will be continuing to study my
career
and hopefully we'll make some videos and
hopefully my um
flu thing you know situation improves
so
there you have it it's day 41 and i'm
just going to press on with what i enjoy
doing and i i really enjoy i just
i've mentioned before it's that you get
that key content
that key content where you like the
voice the rhythm and that's going to get
you because it's the rhythm of the
language if you've got the rhythm you
start saying things correctly your
pronunciation improves
that's what kim jung-ha's content seems
to be doing for me right now
kept that on the transcripts
okay